歡迎收看 最佛心幽默的財經節目
理財達人秀 我是李肇華
今天雖然台股市上漲了270點
不過以整週來說
我們收了一個小黑K
這一週算是漲多反彈之後的壓迴
而且今天的量只有7000多億而已
又再縮下來了
大家在等什麼呢
可能美國的不確定性比較高
例如公債值利率
昨天壓下來 今天又跑上去
油價也始終不上不下的卡在那裡
通通的盈餘沒有消散
在美國現在成為世界的正樣的時候
我們又遇到了有一些產業上的利空
等一下會來一一幫大家做拆單
例如聯發科在疊什麼
聯發科在疊谷歌跟麥威爾的合作
像今天整體的PCB
從載板起頭往下疊
是因為未知數說要攻貨
中國的部分要斷工
這跟台場什麼關係
為什麼現在力空
好像反映的比較明顯
那接下來下禮拜的佈局如何
這是我們每一個禮拜五
最重要的一件事
所以等一下
歡迎三位來賓
來跟大家說分明
第一位是我們的盈利投資
中國中 莊總
好 莊總上個禮拜
就有提到這個禮拜
壓迴的機率非常高
果然出現了壓迴
但到這邊夠不夠呢
中大膽說他希望還能再下去一些些
讓大家會有更好的買點
尤其今天量能縮到這樣的程度
法人都很光望很籌促
今天長什麼呢 長塑化航運
這樣的情況下如何做操作
他有發現到資金跑到哪裡了
高質利率這個是中大膽的專長
等一下幫您講
排面上例如今天肌體模組開始動了
還有一些像塑化骨 水泥骨等等的
到底我們該把資金放到哪裡
中大膽有解答
第二位是我們的國家集基金操盤手
黃豐凱 凱克
凱克今天來剛剛講的產業性的利空
全部交給他啦
有這個觀眾朋友問說聯發科怎麼了
沒有怎麼了
其實就是麥威爾跟谷歌的合作
事實上不會真的殺傷聯發科
等一下告訴你整個EthiC的狀況
還有今天
這個所謂的ABF的伯摩大廠說
他要停工中國一些產能
那我們的宅板在疊什麼呢
我們的通波機板PCB間疊成一片
所以今天凱哥會來幫您做一個釐清
梳理整體來說
對我們台廠的PCB是好是
所以等一下來聊囉
第三位是我們的超馬專家
前陣小哥
哥也要說到底航海網有沒有回來呢
似曾相似的感覺來囉
這個航海我們有講
第一天講海辦信辦影
長到今天需要小哥來幫我們解釋了
上海集裝箱指數
已經連八周的上揚了
原來的那些籌碼
又沒有回來
而記憶體跟CPU也幫我們做檢驗
因為現在記憶體長到模組去了
小哥今天獨家教學
如果發現可轉載
但市場所謂的高益價
約於花高高的錢去買
後面很有戲喔
今天有珍貴的表哥
要提供給大家喔
好 首先有請中大膽
是
莊大膽上禮拜就有提醒
這個禮拜壓迴的機率很高
果然是壓下來了
但是你有提到
因為量還是相當的辛苦需要補量
模組這種高質利率的
AS服氣傳產高質利率的
今天倒是稱盤要降
是沒錯
今天終於禮拜五又收紅了
好久沒看到禮拜五收紅了
所以到底要不要呢
我們看市長上今天的一個
比較屬於利多的部分
就是在外銷的部分
公布的外銷七月份是九百七十九億
YOWI是六十一點九個百分之一
連續十八紅
看起來這個部分應該是還不錯
但為什麼看起來這個盤
市場上就量就很低
然後看起來還有是尾盤
靠著一些全值股把它拉起來
否則今天的整個指數
並不是很好看
那最久因素是在於說
大家看一下
這邊的YOWI六十一點九
下個月預估是六十一點四
到六十四點八
如果你這樣看圖的話
其實他在這個位置就是
下個月
這可能會比較偏向走平的
更何況這個月8月份到目前為止
台幣大概是升值快5毛錢
所以相對在這個匯率的部分
營收的估值的歪歪的部分
可能稍微就會比較偏向
在這個預估的下雨的部分
那下個月可能會破千億的部分
到時候下個月再來看
那我們來看一下這個可能上上
美國的財政財長這邊就有四隻
稱一天美債之利利又談回去
我們看這波到整個股市
為什麼大家覺得說
買起來會覺得不踏實
就是我常提到過
就是像稻穹指數
這一波是最創新高的
那稻穹創新高呢
如果這邊拉回是因為科技股
就你們台積電
是因為科技股的上漲
那合理嘛 資金一來這裡
但問題是科技股最近下跌
包括廢半 它也可以下跌
那就讓人家覺得
創新高的然後類股輪動的話
如果科技股拉回的時候
它竟然沒有跟著拉回
沒有往上漲
更換又來到重要的長期軍線位置
月線換句話說
上上對整個走勢
就比較騙人是用中線角度
不過今天晚上應該會來這邊撤
這邊應該適早會由先所穩的部分
那台灣的ADR的部分呢
今天的台積電是在尾盤流沙圍
撐一下
不過還是蠻辛苦是因為
這邊的一個前幾次的一個高點
產生一個新的一個下降區視線
那各位也可以放
就他先前過這個下降區
換句話說
他現在位置有在這邊
其他部分的整理
重點是現在大家要注意一下
這條叫做黃色的線叫季線
目前季的位置
這個扣底這個位置
逐漸往上扣
也就是說
台積電ADR如果持持沒有往上攻
季線的位置就逐漸會往下來
下彎
這個對台積電ADR的走勢
所以相對會有一些壓力的部分
讓我回到苔果
苔果我之前遇到 預估過了
長兩個禮拜
好好把握 因為我有把握
可以長兩週
長兩週之後
我就沒把握
果然是沒把握 真的是拉回了
拉回這一週
這禮拜是週亮 4.26兆
亮說價跌
我上次提到過
一個雙哀效應
讓整個大盤來到
來到4萬6千500點
我上次有可比提高過
4萬以下或4萬6以下
來的機會都可以來得到
因為那個叫做可以來攻得到
但是如果真要上去的話
台股真實力的考驗
就在4萬6千500點以上
考驗失敗 拉回
那如果是這樣的話
這破贏失去
4萬6再攻的機會了
短時間我是在想不出
有什麼樣的
這個效應的部分
更何況現在大家也在等待
下禮拜兩個不確定
因為叫揮打的財報
這是比較屬於個別公司
一個是JSON後全球央行的看法
尤其這次又是華許的
第一次在全球央行JSON後
來發表看法
所以我想這個部分
可能也叫成市場上
都在做一個觀望
我們來看一下
這波我為什麼認為說大盤
近期來講的話
我個人認為
人會是45676以上會有壓力
怎麼說呢
我們之前提到過
3938是這邊有兩天的1.1兆的
總共2.2兆
在哪邊出現換手
就在這邊
就是我們來看一下
又再了一個
就在這4萬5左右
原本應該是這邊買的
這邊賣到給這邊
然後後來一個叫做
剛剛我講的雙挨效應
讓這邊的換手往上攻
很巧的
這兩天又是1.1兆多
就1.1兆
換句話說
這邊賣給這邊
這邊現在要供的話
你叫我一個 再來一個1.1兆
看起來今天都已經來到8000億以下了
如果短時間要1.1兆
我實在是比較難想像
現在有什麼樣的資金 意志
更況最近的法輪也有比較保守一部分
這一波比較弱的
我個人能夠近期來講的話
是比較觀察重點是在
美元指數及轉弱
當然美元指數轉弱不到100以上
最主要是日元的走強
所以日元走強
市場上考慮的東西就多了
到底要不要趕快還日元
這個很重要的
尤其各位就看一下
這一波的大盤的走勢
前面這邊叫合理的拉迴
因為這邊借太多
這邊的拉迴就是跟日元大幅的升值
各位要想到
高市預期應該會讓9月份
日元要做升息
換句話說 你有沒有發現
台股的走勢
現在跟日元的走勢會有一點很相似
所以說日人這邊在趕快在左邊
市場上前又趕快可以跑出來
做這個五本生意
不是五本
小利息的成本的部分
但是這個大盤也不會掉到哪邊去
最好的位置43,119.7月份的收盤
這邊會有大支撐
所以我個人認為說先破月線
主體之後再上工會比較好一點
因為什麼
因為現在45676有壓力
今天收完盤
你這個位置也差不多不到一趴
一趴誰要進來
大戶不會進來的
只有什麼零星的錢才會跑進來
所以各位講大戶不會進來的
因為空間太小了
空間有限 很空間太小
所以短時間來講就是
國際的國債的殖利率高
高股息殖利率
最近為什麼會那麼強
就是這個原因的部分
好 那我們來看一下
最近有一些個個玩意蠻強的
之前有講到委屈的紅藤
當然股災還是有在稍微探底
但最近也彎上來了
今天漲停板表態
所以離當時降已經20%了
這更厲害了
新產本來就是很傳統的避風股
但這一波已經不是避風了
是變標股環環往上升
最近包括中債保
這相關的常務保險公司都大漲
那這個MACI
主任給我一個可能
因為至少當時候
這個我看到這個價值
那後來也把它納入納進去了
那我們看今天的一些市場上
高大家幾十歲代表公司
所以具有代表就是摩煮的部分
摩煮廠 你看 這個
今天的像舉個例子
摩煮廠創建
他今年上半年的EPS 46塊
YY 24人24倍 恐怖
那這個ANG
12倍 然後群人19倍
那你看 如果以他們今年的鼓勵來算的話
大概就快有4個procent到3個procent
那你要想 這是拿去年的成績
那新年到上半年都已經倍數增長
所以這個隨便加一個一年
大概就五%以上 絕對一定會有
那所以呢 這個威剛你要發現
幾個例子 威剛就很簡單就是
他加工資就是
低檔一定會有個估計五%
直率率的保護
因為今年配18塊
明年不可能低18塊
一定會高於18
19或20或更高
那如果這樣的話
低檔有高補習 直率力保護
但是高檔有什麼 層層的套牢
所以這個就是
大跌的時候你可以考慮一下威剛
然後大漲的威剛就不用考慮
因為層層的套牢就住在這邊
但是確實獲利層長 非常好
對
所以我們今天如果比較激動的
那種快速的
例如說今天模組大漲
你看禮拜一模組這邊就不會大漲
就會稍微休息一下
那如果你要穩健的
這個部分比較屬於穩健型
這一組叫穩健型
穩健型大概就直率六五%
本益比二十倍以下
然後長期穩健
包括有亞歷 聯強能保生機
這邊看起來
今年上半年的EPS
YOLY也都成長
那生機大概馬上從衰退變成持平
不過看起來目前本益比
都在二十倍以下
甚至有些是在十倍以下
我們來看一下
今天會講兩家公司
第一家就是講電子公司的能保
在伺服器代工裡面
雖然是沒有漲多的
沒有漲多 那為什麼放冷保
因為它裡面股信就最穩健的
這個位置你不是要求積極
你要求穩健再求有機會獲利
那公司之前為什麼會比較落後
當然就是相關的AI的步調
稍微慢一點
不過現在大概上次他有公社提到過
今年的非PC的部分要占比較來到四成
然後AI的伺服器要轉強
挑戰美聯的三位數
其實他目前就有各位數的步報
所以治愾部分會幫助他的營收
未來會有加分
那至上營業人也慢慢有做一個增長部分
上半年的EPS 1.1893%
今年EPS我認為有機會挑戰兩塊錢
如果按這樣的幅度來算的話
明年大概有機會發放到1.8
我大概算直率略5%
然後本益比大有17倍左右
所以我們來看一下股價走勢
哪裡是底部 眼睛看就知道
這裡就是底部
你最大的風險大概就在這裡了
因為什麼
這是位置
大量位置也在這裡
換句話說
你在這位置就是
等待什麼時候有機會再做一個
所謂的拉回再往上攻
因為大家的成本都相當
更為這個大戶都在這裡
告訴你我在車裡撐住
所以你就不用擔心
只是說就是量比較小一點
最近跌下來的時候
發現還好
股價的拉回幅度也是有限
因為都已經來到回到
原先這邊的氣漲點
大概35塊附近
對 所以我覺得這個部分
倒是對文件型的等於我們來講
可以考慮
很容易判斷
這個破下去就是要停損
如果看起來的話
這邊打底那麼久
應該算是夠大的底部了
另外一家是亞尼
亞尼這家公司
大家看應該對他大概就會概念
反正現在水泥就是
營收是小幅衰退的
也不會大變動
因為他每年營業
就是差不多這樣子
完整就是跟臺尼
跟臺尼 跟亞尼大家一起分
那加你這些比較小的
那個部分就一部分
反正就是他們營業
每個人都是固定差不多700億到800億
不過他的轉投資的
相關的電力事業
還有最近大家看航運股的育民
他也股價來到相對高
這邊對他有貢獻
你看一下他今年的上半年
一批是已經2.13了
連增將近66個%
營業力長年
有都是維持在10%左右
今年EPS應該有機會調動三塊半
那大概算算以今天的股價來看
北壹比差不多10倍左右
重點是在這裡
各位去看一下
大家也就會知道外資的思考模式
你看 它每年都配下兩塊多
每年都配你兩塊多
我們家公司也算大了
然後如果今年EPS
可以調到三塊半的話
我要算今年的發放力的話
大概可以達到2.7元
股息值力大8%
8%左右 那我們來看一下
好
這邊一個大戶外資在這裡
外資在這裡 那你想
你拿3萬5拿去放銀行
對
一年才花你多少錢
沒多少錢 一%多
那你現在每年都給你2000塊錢
以上的利息
你用4萬塊你每年5%
拿2000塊都夠
更何況現在還不到4萬塊
換句話說
這些外資的算盤都很清楚了
我放在這邊
放在銀行也拿不到2%的利息
這邊至少有6%到7%的利率
更何況他不味道
更何況他還有高進值的部分
所以這種價值股的公司就是
底部不知道怎麼的時候
但如果知道他的底部的時候
那大家很清楚了
這叫連線 這叫月線季線
大家的成本都一樣的時候
那就沒有所謂的
太多的套樓賣壓的部分
那沿得上短時間這部分的量
慢慢的滾上去
我個人認為說這部分應該是有利
到未來會往上攻的部分
投資就可以回到非常非常簡單
對不對
剛剛一看這個底部用眼睛看就知道
這個也是啊
用眼睛看
這邊就是越接近30塊
完全直立率就拉得超級
每年配你兩塊錢
每年兩塊都兩塊多
對 又不會倒
非常簡單的方式
非常謝謝鐘總
謝謝趙華
好 鐘大膽也有提到
這個禮拜果然是壓迴
有一些法人的態度也轉為
真的是比較觀望 亮能縮起來
如果上檔空間有限
大戶資金恐怕有點難進來
但也可以發現一件事
資金跑去哪裡呢
跑去很容易計算值利率的
有保底的
像剛剛講的不管是人保
或者是其他的像雅妮這樣的公司
值利率有保底
底部很明確
雅妮又是一個集團裡面
可以交叉任列
股息的一家公司
所以高速寧
如果現在資金想避風
優先選擇這樣的公司
近代如果在進行有修正的時候
就是我們大舉出手的好時機了
那廣告回來 操盤手要上場了
凱哥要來跟大家講
連發科疊了四五天
再疊哪一條
是不是有點挫殺了呢
那另外呢
ABF載板
今天其實所有的板材都在疊
裡面凱哥覺得機會又來囉
市場氣氛都會微妙的轉變
前一陣子大家就說
利多好像都有發酵了
但最近有很多的產業利空
在這一週
本來覺得沒什麼的
也開始在做發酵了
所以這邊的氣氛改變
就要來請教凱哥了
因為氣氛改變
有時候往往醞釀的就是機會
我們不是說麥威爾
跟谷哥要合作嗎
大家想說那你這個博通發格
可能就會被一腳踹出去
發哥連碟其實就是給機會
再來未知素的公司
很多人知道他是做未素的
但現在是博模的大公司
他現在要斷工中國 奇怪咧
他斷工中國我們台廠已經為什麼
PTV疊一片
對 所以就是航情
當市場進入比較盤整或空頭的時候
基本上利空他就會影響到股價
所以就是利多不漲 但是利空會疊
基本上馬威爾跟這個Google的合作
確實他把博通踢出去
是
對 我們大家可以看到
他真的把博通踢到門外
也沒有踢很遠
但是發哥也莫名其妙被提出去
我們等一下看一下
基本上我覺得他有點被挫殺了
好
那為這行情基本上
因為其實我們現在油價很尷尬的位置
尷尬 真的
油價很尷尬
大家覺得好像快要怎麼樣
快要打了
所以其實市場上有點
慌慌
其實我們剛才投心也是這樣子
投心現在轉去高股息
中東講高股息
8月19日這一天
其實川普發了一個重訊
他說我要對他怎樣
我要對
伊朗實施經濟制裁
我沒有要真的去打他
所以這個搞不好會有一些變化
就是大家希望打
可是最後是沒有打
所以這股市接著氣氛怎麼樣
就開始緩起
大盤角度其實你看他其實就是守在這個位置
其實他守在這個位置
所以我一直覺得
其實這個大盤有高手在互
是
對 已經互三天了
其實你看從這個角度看出來
其實他在前三天就開始打腳
是
雖然大家覺得不太看好
都覺得會疊會疊
可是他怎樣 他就慢慢的拉起來
目前就是利多不漲
但是利空會跌 會反應
但是呢 麥歐歐爾他跟這個TPU
這個東西就是他跟Google
要進行一個深度的合作
所以他要讓Google認股
認股 對
認股這件事情他想說
我們的發哥都沒有讓Google認股了
居然馬菲爾讓這個Google認股
所以他覺得說
這個好像近了一點
這個就這樣遠了一點
但其實你可以看一件事情
就是現在就是
博通過去統包 Google TPU
這事情看起來不會再發生了
因為你看聯發科進來了
馬維爾進來 AMD也想要進來
所以表示 Google TPU這個餅怎麼樣
非常的大
所以它不會只有一家
也不會只有兩家
它會有很多家都進來
那現在大家看的就是馬維爾
對聯發科的影響是什麼
其實馬維爾最強的其實是在通訊
尤其是在網通的部分
所以其實大家看馬票
都是看光通
對 光通
對 所以只要馬票大漲通
光通就會跟著大漲
是
所以他跟發科走的是不一樣的路徑
所以聯發科在這次的過後tpu
他是一個主導的地位
是
所以目前看起來
在這個世代
到今年到明年
看起來都是聯發科主導
是
所以AMD是要進入下一個世代
所以也不會是馬上的
所以在馬票
麥爾消息還沒出來之前
其實AMD的消息就已經先出來了
所以這個聯發科就連續被打了好幾根
那這事情對聯發科有沒有什麼大影響
看起來
今天是長的
所以感覺是影響不太大
但是你看其實
我認為影響比較大的會是臺灣的這兩家 ASIC
為什麼 因為過去其實這個東西其實大家
沒有很重視 所以大廠都沒有跳進來
現在是 AMD也要進來 麥克爾也要進來
所以告訴你
創意跟私心ky
就會有一點點的尷尬
不過還好是因為這兩家其實都
是守在台積電的旁邊
而且背後這樣創意台積電子公司
是因為他亞馬遜也有投資他
是 就是說
因為大家最終都還要來台積投票
所以這兩家還是有一個
競爭的一個 護衛的一個角色
所以他就不容易怎樣被取代掉
不能被取代掉
我們看聯發科
你看 跌好幾天今天怎麼樣
今天投信發覺自己好像殺錯了
這邊真的很可憐
對不對
今天投信突然發現自己好像錯了
很多 連續賣了好多天
發哥的不明
你看今天這樣殺生龍龍
其實他今天反而怎麼樣
蜘蛛了
不能賣
因為什麼
外資根本就沒有大賣
外資根本沒有大賣
但是聯發科的型態
日K是這樣走
這是他周K
那其實你可以看他
他過去長了一段之後
其實就是在反應Google TPU
所以他就回檔做一個修正
所以他正在這個區間裡面
所以我覺得
其實他下來
其實給你一個很好的買點
很好的買點
只是說你要怎麼去操作它
操作它
你看這邊的大量大概在這裡
是
所以這邊我覺得就是有點超疊了
超疊了
是可以留意的
就是研發科的部分
確實最近是投信賣得比較多
投信賣得比較多
不過無所謂
因為投信現在就是
會追高殺低
這是投信的特色
怎麼突然出現了凱哥的經劇呢
所以我說
創新高你追你害怕
會怕
打下來疊你也害怕
那怎麼辦
我們要看這個形態
我們要看這個型態
就是我們要抓住這個型態
所以我跟大家講說
其實你要先找什麼
領先創新高的
領先創新高的族群告訴你什麼
我是有料的
所以你不用理會現在
這個利率要怎麼走
油價要怎麼走
不重要
因為他們會領先創新高
就是要說你
他根本沒有在在乎這些因素
所以反而是什麼
有利空消息的壓迴
就是給你好一個買點
所以我們來看一下後面的部分
你看載板這個位置數
他要斷工什麼
其實他斷工的是中國的PT載板
到底我們今天為什麼PTB疊那麼慘
因為有利空
大家覺得好像怎麼樣
他的料會沒有辦法完全空出
我們可能也會不夠
但是想太多了
想太多
因為台灣其實確實在ABA不要積極的擴充
對啊
他料不夠
所以他告訴大陸說
我沒有辦法供給你這麼多
因為我要先給台灣
這樣解釋就舒服了
所以台灣是很好的一件事情
所以大家不要往負面想
大家老是
只要一看到利空就想要怎麼樣
就想要賣股票
其實這種危險
那再來就是
目前看起來我之前講過嘛
其實不管是台積
不管是英特爾
他們都造成
ABF載板的兩率不夠高
要持續的擴充產能
目前這四家
都在擴充
除了南電比較慢一點以外
可是南電現在看起來也要積極擴充
也要擴充
對 上半年他還在傻傻的
現在看起來他
已經發覺不太對了
因為他再這樣下去
其實緊縮很快就會超越南電
以產能來講
所以南電怎麼可能會允許這種事情發生
所以而且像今年
他們整個南亞集團賺很多
所以過通根本不是問題
不是問題
所以他現在積極的擴充產
所以我覺得這些股票殺下來
其實是給你一個好的
觀察跟買進的一個位置
我們可以再看下一頁
下一頁是星星
先從這邊
先盤中打到跌停
盤中跌停
對 又誰在殺
是頭心跟散戶在殺
外資什麼
外資趁機減便宜
其實外資過去這段時間
已經都一直在賣了
一直在賣
周星期他其實是已經創新高
壓迴
所以我說他是壓迴給你好買點
尤其通常股價這樣子
過高之後的壓迴
通常都是過高壓迴來整理的
不是說他是走空
你要擔心的是
過高有沒有爆大量
如果爆大量就要很小心
可是你看星星的大量
其實出現在這裡
他不是出現在這裡
所以是不太一樣
不太一樣
接下來看
錦塑
剛剛講快要超車難點了是不是
但是錦塑今天也有點被sab得到
今天頭興跟外資都結滿
但是我覺得好事是
基本上這一波的頭興是大買錦塑
就是說
他過去是不看好錦塑
他過去就看好3037
很比氣3189
有到這種程度嗎
就是他們最愛就是他
最愛是這一三星
這個感覺是歐美斯不及格的孩子
可是現在感覺好像有不同的觀點
因為他已經知道說
緊縮目前的產能要大幅的擴充
而且緊縮在9月份的
在9月份的SIMI的這個展
裡面會秀出來
未來的他們的這個技術論壇
會有下一代的設計的變化
9月的半導體戰很重要
所以基本上過去
緊縮沒有在幹這回事
他沒有技術論壇
這次要特別辦技術論壇
所以告訴你
他們有一些比較特別的東西
P的東西
那錦碩基本上你看這是粥
粥的大量D就差不多在這裡
它就在這個地方整理
所以它今天也是收一個角
所以我覺得還是可以觀察
而且它離大量D也沒有太遠
也沒有太遠
所以我覺得是打下來是給你買的
但是這一波錦碩
它還是沒有把這個千糕給突破過去
對 因為老大老二都已經過去了
南電星都已經過高了
所以接下來就換它
好
那曾寧可能就稍微差遠一點
因為曾寧他比較多的是
他有HDI的載到
他有一些消費
HDI的PCB版
這個影響會稍微比較大一點
接著看這個是CCL的族群
CCL的族群其實也是
領先創新高的族群
台光電線創高 但壓回了
對
但是你看
今天雖然都跟著下來了
可是
今天外資也還是站在買放
我覺得最要觀察的就是
這些科技股
其實投信都是站在賣房的
對
因為投信現在就拼命在買高股型
都買中總的股票
所以就把這些通通丟出來
但在他們丟出來的時候
就是一個好的買點
其實有時候股票這樣
就是他們殺下來也不買
等他拉上去的時候你又買不到
你看臺光店的型態是這樣子
這是日K
之前這個大量出現在這裡
所以這邊基本上
他沒有對應的大量
所以他不算是出貨
他沒有出貨
這跟大量根本在這邊
都沒有出現過
所以它是一個買點
那你周客型態基本上
它上週已經創新高了
所以說它拉回來是要找買點的
那我們來看
以日K的型態
我們要怎麼找買點
日K型態
因為這一根是大量
所以你只能從上面找買點
上面找買點
就是它如果過這裡
你就還要再買回來
過這裡就6000以上
因為目前看起來
它的產能已經領先抖山了
已經你先抖散了
對
所以他看起來
市場還在往這個擴
為什麼
因為你不管是
灰打或是 AMD
或是 TPU
基本上
都需要 CCL 嗎
都需要 CCL
所以你可以從 CCL 的設備場
就可以知道目前是很吃緊的
是
凱哥為什麼我不等他快要回測月線的時候
剪作
測交易
滿難的喔 我覺得
因為他已經過高
他就不可能再回到月線
我太容易回那麼深了
除非有系統性的
你可以留意就是十日線
我可以留意十日線
其實我們看的下一檔就是苔藥
苔藥 其實苔藥相對上
它比較落後
可是你看投信也在買
投信蠻喜歡苔藥的 投信也在買
因為很簡單的邏輯
老大是台光店
台光店的股價出於2,000-3,200
是
3,200現在在哪裡
現在它才在1920的最高
還要再出於2,200
還很遠 再出於2就苔藥
3,200我覺得
至少再打個75折
應該就有機會啦
打個75折
所以投信其實一直很喜歡他
但是他建議也稍微落一點
因為他今天把大量高給跌破了
但是我覺得他還會再站回去
不用擔心
因為目前他也很積極在擴產
所以目前看起來
反而是台光
因為他前去年就開始擴了
所以今年就沒有什麼
在大擴產能的條件
但是台要要注意的是
今天的外資大賣
我要講一件事情
這件事情可能對
臺藥相對會比較不利
什麼事
就是說
第一個是它的大量高跌破
大家要注意的是
這一根大量低不可以跌破
不能再跌破
因為它要發CB的
好 又是CB
對 它要發CB的
所以你要注意
它是這裡整理完之後
往上跟著臺灣店一起走
還是先下來再往上走
這就要很仔細的觀察
因為最近的外資
已經開始在腳底抹油了
沒關係等他發CB
我們就叫小哥來講
他的CB到底怎麼樣
好 接著就是
整個PCB相關的材料跟設備工資
這波反彈弱
因為我知道很像
對 可是我剛剛講
其實他們都還是很缺
但是你看
間點有一個很尷尬的位置
什麼
就是他大量高出現在這裡
對啊 就這邊量那麼大
所以這裡就有壓力
這裡就有壓力
雖然投信在買
可是也未必能夠穿越這個位置
所以可以觀察一下
就是說
到他穿越了
應該是整個都上來
對 因為專真不是各PCB廠
都說很缺
對
就是說他如果能夠到這裡
表示像CCL
台要 台光都已經上去了
所以他可以當作是一個落後指標來參考
那PCB的龍頭
基本上最近
也開始有一點點回升
頭線為什麼可以砍到這種程度
對 可是他砍完之後
其實他也慢慢有點買回來的味道
他也沒有一直往下殺
但是你可以注意到就是
你看它大量在這裡
大量在這裡
它業績也好啊
所以表示這邊
它只要再過這個高
它就會往上走
但我覺得它現在是
重新站回千元之後
有一點整理的味道
整理的味道
因為畢竟這個形態很醜
對啦 壓力太大
形態是這樣子往下走的
所以我覺得它勢必是要回來整理一下
那如果它這邊可以站穩
我覺得是蠻不錯的喔
為什麼
因為這裡有一個大量
這裡也有一根大量
如果這根大量高可以站上
那他就應該會往上去
我覺得這個形態相對是比較漂亮
因為金像鏈的粉絲也很多
大家都帶金像鏈
大家都期待著把金像鏈帶回來
這邊非常謝謝可可
奇怪了 市場上覺得應該是利空的消息
在可可解釋之後就會覺得
那跌下來的這些相關股票
反而出現了去購買他的契機
就如同發哥
馬貝爾他其實光通這一塊
是比較多的
跟tpu做這個IC設計這邊呢
有點不一樣
發哥並沒有被踢出去
這邊要留意了
那剛剛也另外提到
PCB今天跌一片
有很多其實從馬上的因素
有可能遇到前面大量的壓力了
頭腥有一些調節等等的
但從產業面上來看
不管載板CCR等等的
他們的發展趨勢
目前沒有任何的改變
而且未知數
有可能是優先提供給台商
好 廣告回來小哥要上場啦
航運股是不是又來了
好熟悉呀
我們禮拜五了
再看所謂的上海集裝箱指數
等一下幫您從馬座解析
還有像CPO 記憶體模組等等的
以及剛講到的可準債
如果有人一家去買
代表什麼樣的訊號呢
到底下個禮拜如何佈局
因為今天盤面上有出些一些
好像傳產上來接棒
這樣的變化
從籌碼上來看呢
到底是不是能夠延續
就要來請教我們小哥啦
因為今天的狀況是
已經反彈過了
但是有一點指數的壓力
但是航運股來了
這個
剛剛我們在看資料的時候說
怎麼熟悉的味道
又要回來了
禮拜五在追 像21年的感覺
對 在追運這樣
好 階級監視長模組
CPU其實長跌
主力到底在不在
今天要教大家喔
好久沒講這個了
為什麼要用易降喔
就是比原本的轉換價還要貴
去買這個可轉債
到底原因是什麼
對啊今天可以來
複習一下
最近的新聞都走這個
復古風
好復古喔
四季啊
SCA-FI啊
那馬上升
這個升財色指路喔各位看一下
8月10號上調全年財色31%
收標漲25%
這就是航運
這航運
航運你看
最重要原因是因為
這SCEFY的印價指數
4月一路走高
來到3500點
在過往疫情的時候
疫情過那一年
不是集裝相運價指數大漲
那時候最高漲到5000點
5000點
現在3500點
其實也漲蠻多
也漲蠻多了
貨櫃海運營再現疫情農警
所以現在這些像是考古體一樣
是 考古體
美中線運價衝上1萬美元
你看考古體跟以前很像
衝突升溫以前沒有
不過這種紅海航到持續壽主
同航壽縣港口雍色
這都是航運股上漲的關鍵字
巴拿馬運河
對 八韓音樂
現在還有來音合
對 那你看
那最懂韓國的男人
顏義財 又來了
顏董又出現了
我們聽了很久的潘董
現在是顏董了
對 相信顏董年底就懂
是 還有很多首富之爭
回來再顏董了
對 顏董說
地緣政治 尊嚴率下降
傳奇嚴惑
這些韓國籍可望延續到10月
他最懂海韻的
是 最懂海韻的男人
對 所以這看起來
海運沒什麼問題
從新聞看起來沒問題
我們就要來驗證一下
看籌碼到底怎麼樣
這籌碼好到不得了啊
各位看一下
首先來看長榮
收完價250塊
251塊 漲給我2%也還好
關於零線33%算蠻溫吞的
對 電子的話這沒什麼
但是以傳產來說
居然有關零線33%呢
對 可是你知道航運內股
這個標長那個年
是
這33根本不算的
那時候都漲100 200%以上
對
好
那各位看到主食
主食各位
成幾何時你有看過主食40的
好
這個有人在問
就主力10天 5天
什麼其中都怎麼看
小哥有說10以上就不錯了
0到10就
這個小買了
那10到20都買
20以上就大買
所以40
這是大大買
大大買
這40很難等
其實這個指數
通常來到40 50
都算是很頂了
好 爆買
爆買
那住了要430
外資聯買6天
所以代表說
航越股的
籌碼非常的好
首先來看長龍
你看
這是開步零言上軌
真的耶
我們有說
這種現行是最強的
沒錯
漲不停比漲停還厲害
你看現在是漲不停的狀況
漲不停
然後主力聯買
外資聯買分點也是聯買
所以這是一個
籌碼非常漂亮
投信很猶豫
要不要跟啊
要不要追
但有投信有買散裝
有有有
這個主動型ETF有買
這個後面就會買了
因為你看到後面這樣漲
再不追整個機械都比人家差了
那我們怎麼辦呢
我們怎麼辦
我們是不是要再當一次航海王了呢
其實我們看一下
他這邊呢
他從起漲到現在
大概從20到254
其實大概就一根
一根多長頂蠻
一成多
所以其實我覺得
腳有下跌的時候
你都可以跟上
來看下一個陽明
陽明也很漂亮
各位看
這邊整理這段線
這整理非常漂亮
各位你看一下它的貸寬
貸寬大概6 7而已
很窄的貸寬
超級窄
非常窄的貸寬
一開布林
就是要讓你跟上
像這種
即便它有長頂
你都不能空他
因為這種陷阱都很漂亮的
主力都連買了
主力連買
所以這陽明這也不錯
不過從開布林到現在
這長得有點快
長得有點快
長得大概快30%
所以這個
陽明
你繳這圈
這個還沒買的
你還是等他回來
這是最強的
今年新高萬海
6天暴漲預4成
最強就差不多
所以看起來買長廊好像稍微安全一點
是
傳比較大支
對傳比較大支
主投外資
各位看
主力也買
外資也買
然後分點也是連買
對
也是開不去連續上檔
好陡啊這個
這很漂亮
那這種
可惜的事
怎樣
他那個
沒有
沒有那個
最近還沒有那種
被關的風險
假如他有被關的話
其實
蠻不錯的
搞不好會啊
他還沒有嗎
有機會我覺得
再拉下去一定會有機會
再拉下去有機會
那只要之後被關
被關都是很好買點
只要被關是不是貨櫃航運
觀觀觀越關越大
你的事情又要來
對 因為這種被關之後
假如同住群又被關
那代表說
這個族群就是未來的主角
通常我們處置股
看到同住群都出現
那最近就要
這個族群
所以萬海呢
這個還不錯
我們就希望他有機會被關
真的是刻在我們台灣股民裡面的
航海王機在蠢動
然後另外一個當然記憶體機
對記憶體
南亞科也很厲害
對南亞科也是在新高的附近
華方店就追著比較慢一些些
那為什麼
因為華方店的籌碼比較差
你看華方店的籌碼長線是往下
南亞科的籌碼最近是往上
就是主力和大戶特別喜歡南亞科
對
南亞科的籌碼不錯
任何拉回來
因為這月線往上了嘛
任何拉回來靠近月線的時候
都是好賣點
而且南亞科整理完是創高的
所以這個型態是很漂亮的
在電子股裡面
記憶體最先拉回最先創高
所以我覺得記憶體後面還有行情
後面還有行情
那黃鑣店因為籌碼差的關係
比較累一點
所以這兩個選擇我會比較喜歡選南亞科
還是選南亞科
現在市場投票都是投到南亞科
因為從籌碼看起來就這樣
這種籌碼不好
有的最近有長這種都是跟長
我們要買這個領長的
不要買這種根長
因為根長很容易有個風吹草動
它一定要跌下來
除非它籌碼變好
對 除非籌碼變好
目前籌碼沒有變好的現象
好 現在看這個
傳說機體魔術上
剛剛鐘大膽有講到威剛
至少以質地率來看很甜
但是你看它這個型態是走的
扁平壯在地上
扁平壯 各位
你看一下近4季
77塊 最近這30幾塊
這看起來我覺得今年破百應該是沒啥問題
EPS
EPS破百沒啥問題
那現在你看一下它的股價
這400多塊
這是有天委屈
對
有點委屈
委屈歸委屈到底籌碼怎麼樣
籌碼最近有稍微慢慢的起來的感覺
慢慢的起來
慢慢起來
所以我覺得威剛看起來蠻不錯的
加油威剛
加油
好
來
現在看大力光
大力光就大力了
大力也沒問題
大力光之前我們有說
那個有個關鍵分點
買在3000的時候大買
山多哥嗎
山多哥對
山多哥
照好記性
因為你一直說他籌碼很好
他真的展現出籌碼好的樣子
那山多哥最近是爆賺了
那山多哥呢
在高檔還把一些股票賣掉
轉去買什麼你知道嗎
川湖
山多哥實在太省了你知道嗎
快樂就是那麼樸實無華
賣5000的買8000買1萬
賣8000的時候跌到6000多
這次該不會踩到鐵板
哇1萬多
沒有1萬多
山多哥下次買什麼一定要好跟一下
山多哥這樣買完
大力光我們之前講
大力光是CPU裡面最漂亮的
是
本益比最低
嗯
這巴黎來漲不欲四成
對啊好猛
這節七月美股欲13.94元
這非常強
那最近籌碼也變好了
這籌碼也不大好
最近籌碼變成聯買
對
那這個投信呢最近也一直在買
所以我覺得
這個
這個大力光很漂亮
巴黎時少就特別有在講過大力光
一直延續這樣
投信不離不棄
繼續不離不棄
真的是
還不錯
你看最近就又又又漲上去了
然後再來看華信光
那華信光各位看
華信光在處置的時候
處置的時候我們最喜歡買
你看他前陣子長到近處置
在前陣子是疊到近處置
我們也長到近處置
那長到近處置這邊
各位 這個位置
這邊有出現一個浪子灰頭好賣點
我們有說近處置的下疊
是讓你買的
然後上升的月線
結果你看
後面又彈上來了
下跌讓你買嘛
後面也彈上來了
所以這個華星光呢
他這個示範的處置的好買點
所以下次有類似股票
這樣子跌了也是讓你買的
好 再來看這個可轉債
可轉債高益價
我們有政治沒講了
高益價最近這個標的蠻多的
好變多了
那我們高益價是個好的買點
那我們再加上主力籌碼的過濾
主力籌碼再過濾一下
我們就可以找到更好的買點
那高益價什麼意思呢
高益價就是說
他CB的圍買
是大於市值10塊以上
對 10塊以上
那我們來看一下
像第一個智上
階級體通路的智上
智上各位看
他這個回敵的時候
主力並沒有大賣
所以他籌碼是不錯的
他也是算高質利率股
對 高質利率有到4%
那各位看一下他的益價
他的CP為買下一道一一三
對
四指在一零三
所以這邊大概多了10塊
那位階也不錯
所以這檔我覺得後面有機會
通常那種意下就是指他的線股有機會對不對
線股有機會
因為這種你買線股是買在一零三的位置
就轉換之後是一零三位置
像這種我們都比較建議你去買線股
好 現在我們看下一檔
下一檔是一七七的長薪
那長薪最近的籌碼也不錯
這個主力買上來之後這邊並沒有掉下來
然後長新呢各位看一下
長新的
長新的這個可轉債的意叫
這意的太誇張吧
意的有點多啊
對啊 怎麼了
這來到132啊
是
買可轉債的人不知道在想什麼
想什麼
在132喔
然後他四值才93而已啊
對
四值才93
然後可轉債買132
欸
他可能覺得長新後面很有機會
所以採用這麼高的這個圍買去買它
這都沒有別的問題嗎
他花那麼多的意價
不知道
因為通常看到這麼大的意價
那籌碼又不錯的
後面常常都會長上去
這個是長新的部分
這是特化
現在看這個361系的塑貼
UPS 這個我實在看不懂
但它實在很厲害
一路上去
那最近的籌碼也蠻漂亮的
主力也是聯買
籌碼漂亮
我們可以看 直率也不錯
有到快4%
那我們就看一下
他的CP的維滿狀況
那碩天3的維滿狀況
CP來到119
市值來到93
其實也不錯
也超過滿多的
這個超過大概20幾
這個型態看起來滿漂亮的
看起來有點像底部的
起漲的狀況
所以這個塑天的各位也可以留意一下
因為他前面其實
有一個高位
雖然最近感覺上強是因為他已經提早可能先落底了
而且這個算是懂得發債的
各位看一下
從高檔跌下來之後才發債
低檔發債
中低檔發債
對 算低檔發債的
算是厲害發債的
有低檔發債
有直立率
有這個高意價
我覺得科轉在三大上漲的要注
他都有了
所以各位這邊
你可以特別留意線股的部分
好 其實最近有很多木資的公司
都被先打下來
是
但是木完之後科轉在發行
我沒有多了一個可以觀察的商品
沒錯
其實是很不錯的
對 我們做股票
就是理由要多一點
是
來了
最後一個看市委行
曾經是腰骨
腰骨
全正值也是整理得非常久
對啊
最近跟著航運走上來
對
那各位看
這個籌碼也不錯
這邊是連兩根漲停的
隔著沖跑掉
今天又進來了
所以這符合這種
腰骨的節奏
因為之前
哥有教過我們
他是很罕見
隔日沖連沖七天
是
很厲害
七根漲停半
對 沒錯
所以好像是以前非常標的
各位看一下
CPUM在113
市值在96
市值在96代表說
再拉一下一定過轉人架
所以這一檔我覺得拉起來
換的機會蠻高的
有新人又回到了四維行的身上
所以這個骨子裡面的航海王基因
大家可以考慮一下
至少籌碼真的很好
今天非常謝謝小哥 謝謝
看籌碼真的很有趣
尤其是我們看到航海王
我們從星期五
在看到上海集裝箱指數等等的
過去的回憶又開始敲打我們了
但萬萬沒有想到的是
是籌碼真的好到爆炸
不過這個很見仁見智
我們常常講
船展在漲 AI又好厲害
那這邊的話
也許你做一個分散的配置
因為畢竟這一塊
目前籌碼非常的好
要緊定一下運價跟籌碼的狀況
能不能連續的往上拉
那剛剛也講到了
例如像記憶體 CPO裡面
像CPO大力光的領軍
是真的領軍一段時間了
而其他的有一些籌碼
今天還教您
可轉載的高益價代表
之後對他的股價有所期待
希望大家學起來喔
好 今天星期五的晚上
非常謝謝三位朋友來到現場
本週是一個壓迴的狀態
但是有發現嗎
來賓們觀測的指標反而多了
好的股票跌下來
反而覺得趕買的念頭上升了
那也希望今天理財單
就對你的投資有幫助喔
下週再會了 拜拜